liquid definitely have
what it takes to take them down is just
not the necessary sustainability to do
so in the best of three
there's no doubt about it yeah they have
to really prove what if liquid can get
this nemesis
off their back it's been astralis this
entire year i mean you're right
it did seem like we had like or the
starters had like [ __ ] aligned for us
be considered the best team in the world
and i got so bad every time like even
after our third event win
people were still asking like oh do you
think you're the best team in the world
it's like
now i feel like we're the best in the
world after a second event win i think
there's a lot of pressure on liquid
right now
it's incredibly hard to be the best team
in the world and and do it in the
fashion they did
and then fall back to be just a just a
decent team let's say it like that
a two versus two and liquid have the
advantage they're trying to bring it
down to the two versus one
if it's rpk this drop they could be in
serious trouble that should do it
there we go it's team liquid and that's
what it means to them
[Applause]
team liquid was one of north america's
best cs go team for years
even before 2019 they came painfully
close to glory time
and time again he has to go and fight
and they're getting close he has the
spray coming through he takes out four
as well but he's down to 12 health and
now it's just
all in the details easy for sk to pick
it up here
trying to walk through the smoke but
it's just not gonna happen sk gaming
second major championship in a row they
are your winners
simple heco taco all kinds of incredible
players tried and failed to reach the
top under liquid's banner
arguing bickering bunching tables not
listening
not hesitating
there were of course occasional flashes
of brilliance
but liquid never managed to find
consistent success
barely showing himself gets the head
shot in jdm and now nitro one versus two
there's no time no kit
almost no chance in the world that he
could do this trying to see if he could
swing right out by the hay card but
they're just waiting for him and glade
gets the kill
16 16-10 we just couldn't
close it out in the end again i feel
like it was the small mistakes
we just um i think it'll just come with
experience
those little details but at the end of
2018
after yet another failure liquid created
a new roster
one that felt different nitro was a
team's veteran
brawny igl fending off a full execution
he always seems to deliver here
can he do it one more time
that was the biggest issue in alex falls
he's got another on the a site nitro
he owns that spot now elige was liquid's
long-standing superstar
rifler it'll be elise to try and fight
them one versus four and
he's got the first kill the bomb is
right there solving that's right the
only thing going for him one more
headshot they're gonna find
[Applause]
was a prodigy with the highest
mechanical potential of
any player in an a this is going to be a
pistol round
four phase clan surely one versus three
for twists
the magician oh does he have another
trick in him
one versus two in the bomb still not
planted that's an opportunity that he
missed
moving over towards window how did he
get out he's waiting he knows he's
calling the bluff calling the fake tap
well they have no idea he's here he sees
the gun barrel
he's looking for olaf he's got the
information on one and he's ripped his
way all the way around an easy kill
twist it's magical nath was an
underrated talent who finally found a
place on a team that was worthy of his
skill
nah the only defender here the smoke and
he's just in the angle he's waiting for
it
timing is everything he's gone it can't
be real
and the last piece of the puzzle was
stewie2k the major winning pug star who
just spent a few disappointing months in
brazil playing for mibr
misfit's body waiting a little bit
dear lord stewie
no that's that's that's not allowed that
is disgusting
but the new liquid kicked off their time
together with a huge win
and then they rose through the ranks to
heights they'd never
seen before so he's able to get some
cover and he's been great here as long
as he can hold tight to the pillar he's
gotten the second one nap will fall back
into the pit
and he'll take a second one as well
that's it
neff seals the deal there was a slight
hope for astralis
but it was liquid the late breaking
horses the whole way
while the team synergy obviously helped
there was one other factor behind
liquid's rise team liquid were dubbed
nas astralis
because they pretty much copied the best
team in the world's play style
i do believe like i was copying and
sharing this playstyle well
i mean it's completely true i mean we
did it ourselves uh we believed that
they were like the standard you know
their teamwork and fundamentals should
like we're the standard and like that's
like the bar that we have to like hit
now
but liquid didn't want to be nas
astralis they didn't want to be compared
to anyone
they wanted to be champions in their own
right i mean i don't think any of us
really
like thought of that like being like
a shadow of astralis but that's kind of
what it was throughout all
last year to be fair we were clearly the
dominant second place team
like we're dominating every other team
except the straws
part of liquid's success was ditching
the rigid roles of counter-strike and
letting each player on the team do what
they wanted to in a round
for example liquid didn't have a primary
opera and
every member of the team could either
alert enter or support
our mindset was kind of like if the
stratas did it
i mean someone said it's the best way to
do it then if astralis is doing it
but in this year we kind of just turned
that around it was like no we can
definitely make what they're doing
better
what started as a string of mixed
results at the beginning of the year
ended up as a new era by the time the
summer rolled around
an era defined by team liquid he can
sense players on the other side it's
gonna be a kill for twist shortly he
gets the first
is this where it ends alu in a three
versus one
john but he's got the kill and liquid
habit they've got the championship
they've got masters
and two in the intel grand slam oh my
god eminek get a one versus three
with 19 seconds unbelievable scenes here
ladies and gentlemen team liquid
are your season nine pro league
champions no diffuse kid available here
a two versus two a liquid have the
advantage they're trying to bring it
down to the two versus one
if it's rpk this drop they could be in
serious trouble that should do it
there we go it's team liquid and that's
what it means to them
they've taken it at the fourth map the
favorites coming into the tournament
have just unlocked the intel grand slam
at esl one cologne under the belt
team liquid didn't just win the iem
grand slam they did it in the shortest
amount of time
possible winning four events straight to
earn a million dollars
but for some people even that wasn't
enough to make them the best team in the
world
even after our third event win people
were still asking like oh do you think
you're the best team in the world
it's like now i feel like we're the best
in the world after a second event win
after the grand slam win it's like i
mean the question was still asked
like do you think you're the number one
team now it's like where have you been
man
the haters would say that astralis
wasn't in proper form so
liquid couldn't really call themselves
the best until they beat the real
best team in a serious grand final but
liquid didn't let the doubters get in
their way
they kept steamrolling team after team
guardian 24 seconds he finally gets the
bomb but he's not sure where to go and
this might have been the wrong choice
indeed it is and there we go
team liquid pick up the trophy here at
blasphemy they are your champions
this is absolutely perfect he's got the
perfect angle except
on the other side and he goes down
ladies and gentlemen it's team liquid
you're the engineering street master
chicago
champions liquids win streak continued
up until the break before the berlin
major
and pretty much everyone was taking the
same thing after such an insane
dominant run there was no way liquid
wouldn't win their first major
but the break proved lethal to their
momentum
it's all on this a two on two the last
couple of seconds left a flashbang
to try and buy some more time they don't
have a kit right now
i don't see how they can get this defuse
there's the vice and there's the
16-13 they take down team liquid
and they're gonna be in the semi-finals
in a cruel twist of fate
liquid started losing to astralis over
and over again
again proving that they are the greatest
of all time james
their loss at the blast global finals
was the final nail in the coffin
2019 was supposed to be the year of team
liquid
but it sure didn't end that way and
device already
wanting to come in through mini an
excellent flash zip x takes him down
it's all on naf
ice in his veins can he handle this heat
bomb is tap not planted for him he's got
it down to the 1v1
zfx could very well clutch this if he
sticks it no way
incredible and in 2020 competitive cs go
went online because of the global
pandemic
meaning that liquid never really got
their shot at cs go's most prestigious
trophies
as swift and decisive as liquids rise up
the competitive ladder was
their tumble back down was just as quick
the league's already gonna get in there
nice and fast molotov will make things
awkward modem has dropped one more and
the trades leave it all on to twist
it's not been anywhere near his best
performance but he might be able to keep
them alive
as he looks around the corner he's got
to be careful that there's two players
close and
oc surely spotted him he can't do
anything here
and after a dominant first map in
liquid's favor
cloud9 flip it by taking them now it's
definitely over
lagged by the op and this is it this is
gonna be genji
recovering in bts in these past two
weeks
looking at a whole new level 16 to 9
victory over liquid on vertigo
chip away at the head of vinnie yuri
he's going to stuff that smoke peek from
stewie
and now the two versus four turn all
onto the shoulders of twist
he goes down and we've got the
brazilians on a
two zero advantage in a best of five
launders this is dire straight for
liquid as for liquids bitter rivalry
with astralis well
in 2020 many of astralis players took a
break meaning that
liquid didn't even get their chance for
real revenge on the roster that ended
their reign
team liquid also recently made a pretty
big change to their team
after five years with liquid nitro is
out he's being replaced by grimm
and stewie2k is taking over as igl i'm
honestly really sad to leave
i'm not sure what the future holds for
me but honestly it feels weird not being
under liquid
how this modified roster will stack up
in the new normal for esports is
anyone's guess but one thing is for sure
team liquids rise to the top
and their rivalry with astralis made the
summer of 2019 one of the best moments
in counter-strike history
and liquid is ready to fight to take us
all
back thanks for watching if you want
more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages